todo ser humano es un artista el reto de
la vida es crear arte hermoso esto lo
dijo el escritor miguel ángel ruiz y yo
de verdad creo que todos nos hacemos
artistas todos tenemos un artista
adentro cuando nacemos pero en el camino
nos vamos olvidando nos vamos olvidando
de esa creatividad con la que nacemos y
que podemos desarrollar durante toda
nuestra vida pero que a veces dejamos de
lado pero que es ser un artista
ser un artista es poder conjuntar
lo visible con lo invisible poder
plasmar lo irreal y lo real
hacer una conjunción que inspiren que
brote de tus entrañas y que haga que los
demás sientan tus emociones
transmitir esas emociones y dialogar las
con el espectador
esta parte de ser artista se aplica para
todo no solamente para los que somos
artistas de la plástica ser artista es
ser creativo es ser original es ser
propositivo
esta parte es la más importante que
debemos de llevar todos adelante en la
vida hoy les voy a platicar un poco de
cómo yo me convertí en artista
yo empecé muy chiquita como a los 5 años
más o menos a descubrir estas cosas en
mi vida no y todo comenzó como lo de
siempre con un sueño todos soñamos
cosas diferentes pero no todos llegamos
llevamos estos sueños a la realidad
porque para llevar un sueño en la
realidad se necesita no solamente soñar
sino apasionarte enamorarte de tu sueño
y decidir tomar el toro por los cuernos
e ir por tu sueño hasta las últimas
consecuencias entonces yo era una niña
chiquita y pues nada vela esta vida pasa
por casualidad todo sucede porque somos
un poco el
resultado de lo que nos toca vivir y en
mi casa yo tenía una mamá
estricta dura conservadora
exigente pero ella me enseñó a amar
viajar a descubrir cosas nuevas nuevos
mundos
pero desde la parte práctica porque ya
era práctica y tenía un papá
amoroso lindo soñador cariñoso él me
enseñó a soñar y me enseñó a soñar de
una manera práctica también porque me
inculcó el amor por la lectura y leyendo
puedes volar a todos lados a mundos
lejanos a con fines a todos los tiempos
cuando lees te puedo decir desde el
principio de los tiempos hasta el futuro
lo que existe lo que no existe entonces
tu cabeza empieza a generar mundos
interiores que te dejan soñar y soñar es
el tema de nuestra conferencia de hoy
cómo convertir tus sueños en realidad
más adelante en la adolescencia pues ya
empezaba yo a ver las cosas un poco
diferente manera
había empezado a pintar desde muy niña y
esa parte como de de pintar a mí me
permitía cómo crear esos mundos más
mágicos pero no solo en mi cabeza sino
aterrizarlos en un papel y en la
adolescencia
pues
y empecé a soñar en otras cosas porque
ya empiezas a tener otro tipo de
emociones
pues me volví muy fantasiosa
pero creo que fue como un poco mayor
cuando ya decidí estudiar que me
empezaron a llegar pues esta parte que
nos llega a todos no la responsabilidad
que voy a hacer con mi vida y la verdad
es que ser artista era poco práctico y
estaba como totalmente vetado por mi
entorno o sea cómo que pues que vas a
ser artista y de que vas a vivir que es
eso de ser artista de qué se tratan o
cómo se come
entonces este pues un poco influenciado
por la sociedad por mi entorno decidí
estudiar diseño gráfico
luego diseño industrial que era lo que
más se acercaba a mi pasión
y pues por ahí empecé pero luego pues la
vida siempre te van caminando por el
camino que te toca
y las circunstancias un corazón roto la
vida me llevó a irme de viaje por europa
y en ese viaje descubrí mi verdadera
vocación
encontré
la posibilidad de quedarme estudiar en
florencia en la academia de bellas artes
y pues ahí fue como un boom así en mi
vida que de repente me llegó la
iluminación y descubrí
pues uno yo ya estaba creciendo
empezando a madurar empezando a tener
mis propias ideas dejándome de
influenciar tanto de mi familia y el
haberme ido para allá me dio esa
posibilidad como de alejarme
totalmente de su influencia no
y poderme meter en los museos y volverme
loca y llorar de la emoción cuando veía
como las almas de los grandes maestros
ahí surgir y era una cosa emocionante
era una cosa que ellos decían híjole
esta es una pasión que me sale del alma
y con la que yo quiero vivir y se nota
casi llorando
entonces este
este proceso en el que
encontré mi pasión pues fue super
enriquecedor y la verdad me osea yo
tenía como toda esta energía de esto va
a ser mi vida pero luego regresé a
méxico y me topé con la realidad y pues
con la realidad que cada quien va
creando su realidad pero en ese momento
era mi realidad y entonces puedes seguir
trabajando en diseño yo siempre fui muy
trabajadora y desde antes de irme a
europa yo ya trabajaba en eso tenía un
despacho de diseño y seguir trabajando
en eso y en ese camino conocí de nuevo
me llevo el amor conocí al que ahora es
mi esposo y este y encontré en él
alguien que iba a apoyarme que que iba a
estar conmigo y me iba a ayudar a
cumplir mis sueños entonces después de
un tiempo de que ya estábamos formando
una familia
les pregunté tú qué opinas de si me
dedico esto del arte y entonces él lo
analizó y todo y mi hijo va yo te apoyo
si esto es lo que quieres pues decídete
toma el toro por los cuernos y vas y
pues me lance al vacío pero con certeza
con certeza ya de que eso era lo que yo
quería para mí de que eso era lo que me
haría feliz de que eso era en lo que yo
iba a poder ser proactiva y dejar algo
porque a través de lo que yo pinto yo
saco todas mis emociones y las catapultó
en los lienzos y dejo mis ideas dejó mi
sentir dejo mi corazón
y más adelante empecé a trabajar ya no
estoy y pues claro ahí te vas tapando
con otras paredes porque siempre retos
nada en la vida es fácil nunca nada en
esta vida se va a dar gratis ni va a ser
fácil siempre vas a encontrar obstáculos
gente negativa que te va a decir no tu
no puedes esto no es para ti no tienes
la suficiente hambre o no no tiene ese
toque artista siempre alguien va a
encontrar algún defecto en todo lo que
tú haces no entonces este pues tiene que
tener como mucha determinación y estar
claro en lo que tú quieres y confiar en
ti porque si tú no confianza en ti pues
nadie más lo va a ser y si tú no estás
claro en lo que tienes que hacer no vas
a poder llegar a ningún lado
entonces como puedes
ser exitoso en esta carrera o cualquier
otra carrera siendo único haciendo algo
especial algo que no hacen los demás
entonces yo siempre fui muy curiosa y
siempre fui muy experimental y entonces
busqué maneras de hacer cosas nuevas
dentro de la plástica y desarrolló una
técnica nueva y la patente
esta técnica me ha llevado a viajar por
el mundo a estar en muchos concursos a
ganar muchos premios y a dar a tener
reconocimientos en el extranjero a veces
más que en mi propio país pero también
ahí descubrí algo extra que me iba a dar
ese plus encontré una vocación aparte de
la mía encontré esta vocación de
engrandecer a méxico porque descubrí que
en el mundo entero valorar a los
mexicanos y nosotros ya no hacemos con
ventaja porque tenemos el gen de la
creatividad ese gen no lo tienen todos
los seres humanos del planeta ese gen ya
viene en nuestro adn entonces esa
ventaja con la que nosotros nacemos nos
da la posibilidad de que el mundo entero
a nosotros y haga un mexicano y nos ver
de colores nos ven brillantes nos ven
con nuestros aromas con nuestros sabores
el mundo entero nos valora muchísimo y
ahí descubrí que nosotros lo damos por
hecho porque como todos tenemos un gen
pues se nos hace normal
entonces descubrí que yo tenía que
llevar esa bandera de méxico al mundo
y pues este ha sido mi trabajo y en eso
sigo trabajando y es algo en el que voy
a trabajar toda mi vida porque nunca
podemos nunca llegamos a la meta la meta
no es el punto final lo importante es el
camino es este camino que recorremos
para llegar ahí es lo que nos va
llevando y cómo lo vamos disfrutando y
cómo vamos aprendiendo a ser felices
disfrutando cada paso que damos para
llegar a esa meta que estamos buscando
pero si vamos en conjunto esto siempre
va a ser mejor porque no estamos solos
todos somos un artista en potencia que
cada quien tiene
algo artístico que darle al mundo y por
artístico me refiero cualquier cosa que
ustedes hagan tiene un valor sean
creativos sean innovadores entonces yo
les voy a decir los cinco puntos que yo
digo que se necesitan para lograr un
sueño
el primero tienes que tener un sueño
grande porque si tu piensas chiquito vas
a llegar a algo chiquito pero si piensas
en grande si sueñas en grande vas a
lograr grandes cosas y la verdad es que
a mí no me educaron para ser mediocre yo
tengo que ser excelente porque si no mi
mamá me va a matar
entonces este sueño es importantísimo
que sea grande después tienes que tomar
el control de tu vida y para tomar el
control de tu vida necesitas saber que
te va a costar que va a ser difícil que
te vas a enfrentar muchos retos que vas
a tener que sacrificar cosas pero que
estás dispuesto a darlo todo y que una
vez que arranques no hay vuelta para
atrás
tienes que aprender a enfrentar los
grandes retos las críticas
los problemas económicos
las confrontaciones sociales todo lo que
venga de tu sueño si estás seguro que
eso es lo que tú quieres tienes que
aprender a afrontarlo y tienes que tener
una disciplina de guerrero te tienes que
levantar temprano tienes que ir todos
los días a trabajar tienes que todos los
días ponerte metas
organizarte y no decir ay pues yo voy a
pintar cuando me llegue la creatividad
no la creatividad te va llegando en el
camino tienes que
y trabajar todos los días haciendo es
como se van dando las cosas no van a
llegar solas nadie te va a regalar nada
lo último y más importante es que no va
solo todos vamos juntos todos tenemos un
equipo sí en mi equipo yo no hubiera
llegado a donde he llegado porque cada
uno es un artista en un área entonces
cada uno tiene que hacer su parte pero
si estamos juntos somos un pedazo más
pequeño pero de un pastel más grande y
en lo que tenemos que ir todos juntos
todos los que estamos aquí es en
impulsar a méxico porque méxico es
nuestro nosotros somos méxico no méxico
es una sola persona méxico es de todos y
tenemos que impulsar
entonces
una vez dados estos cinco puntos básicos
yo las quiero invitar a una cosa los
quiero invitar a que soñemos juntos a
que no dejen de soñar a que no dejen de
ver al niño que tienen dentro a que
buscan en su interior cuáles son cuál es
su pasión y entiendan que sin pasión no
se llega a ningún lado y que juntos
vamos a lograr
esta gran pasión este gran objetivo
común de hacer grande a méjico
[Aplausos]